we'll go back to the
gerard zing and we'll come back here why
are we neonus why are we embryonic for
so long
because are we did we just move from the
savannah to the arctic and we need to
learn new stuff
if we came genetically programmed we
would not be able to do that
are we throwing spears or are we fishing
or are we
running an industrial supply chain or
are we texting what is the adaptive
behavior
horses today in the wild and horses 10
000 years ago are doing pretty much the
same stuff
and so since we make tools and we evolve
our tools and then change our
environments
so quickly and other animals are largely
the result of their environment but
we're
environment modifying so rapidly we need
to come without too much programming so
we can learn the environment we're in
learn the language right which is
going to be very important learn the
tool making learn the um
and so we have a very long period of
relative helpless
of helplessness because we aren't coded
how to behave yet because we're
imprinting a lot of software on how to
behave that is useful to
that particular time so our mimesis is
not it's not unique to humans but the
total amount of it is really unique
and this is also where the uniqueness
can go up right is because we are less
just the result of the genetics and
that means the kind of learning through
history that they got coded in genetics
and more the result
of it's almost like our hardware
selected for software
right like if evolution is kind of doing
these think of as a hardware selection
i have problems with computer metaphors
for biology but i'll use this one here
um that
we have not had hardware changes
since the beginning of sapiens but our
world is really really different
and that's all changes in software right
changes in
on the same fundamental genetic
substrate what we're doing
with these brains and minds and bodies
and social groups and
like that and so um
now gerard specifically was looking at
when we watch other people talking so we
learn language you and i would have a
hard time learning mandarin today or it
would take a lot of work we'd be
learning how to conjugate verbs and
stuff but a baby learns it instantly
without anyone even really trying to
teach it just through mimesis so it's a
it's a powerful thing they're obviously
more neuroplastic than we are when
they're doing that and all their
attentions allocated that
but they're also learning how to move
their bodies and they're learning
all kinds of stuff through mimesis one
of the things that gerard says is
they're also learning what to want
and they learn what to want they learn
desire by watching what other people
want
and so intrinsic to this people end up
wanting what other people want
and if we can't have what other people
have without taking it away from them
then that becomes a source of conflict
so the mimesis of desire is the
fundamental generator of conflict and
that then
the conflict energy within a group of
people will build over time
this is a very very crude interpretation
of the theory
can we just pause on that for people who
are not familiar
and for me who hasn't i'm loosely
familiar but i haven't internalized it
but every time i think about it it's a
very compelling view of the world
whether it's true or not
it's quite it's like when you take
everything freud says as truth is a very
interesting way to think about the world
in the same way thinking
about the memetic theory of desire
that everything we want
is imitation of other people's wants we
don't have any original wants
we're constantly imitating others and so
and not just others but you know others
were exposed to
so there's these like little local
pockets however defined local
of people like imitating each other and
uh
one that's super empowering because then
you can pick which group you can join
like what what do you want to imitate
it's it's uh
it's the old like uh you know whoever
your friends are that's what your life
is going to be like
that's really powerful i mean it's
depressing that we're so unoriginal
but it's also liberating in that if this
holds true that we can choose our life
by choosing the people we hang out with
so okay thoughts that are very
compelling that seem
like they're more absolute than they
actually are end up also being dangerous
communism um i'm gonna discuss here
where i think we need to amend this
particular
theory but specifically you just said
something that everyone who's paid
attention
knows is true experientially which is
who you're around affects who you become
and as as libertarian and
self-determining and sovereign as we'd
like to be
um everybody i think knows that if you
got put in a maximum security prison
aspects of your personality would have
to adapt or you wouldn't
survive there right you would become
different if you were
if if you grew up in darfur versus
finland you would be different with your
same genetics like just
there's no real question about that um
and that even today if you hang out
in a place with ultra marathoners
as your roommates or all people who are
obese as your roommates
the statistical likelihood of what
happens to your fitness is pretty clear
right like the behavioral science of
this is pretty clear
so uh the whole saying we are the
average of the five people we spend the
most time around
i think the more self-reflective someone
is the more time they spend by
themselves in self-reflection the less
this is true but it's still true
so one of the best things someone can do
to become more self-determined is be
self-determined about the environments
they want to put themselves in
because to the degree that there is some
self-determination and some
determination by the environment
don't be fighting an environment that is
predisposing you in bad directions
try to put yourself in an environment
that is predisposing the things that you
want
in turn try to affect the environment in
ways that predispose positive things for
those around you
or perhaps also to there there's
probably interesting ways to play with
this you could probably
put yourself like form connections that
have this perfect tension in all
directions to where you're actually free
to decide whatever the heck you want
because
the set of wants within your circle of
interactions
is so conflicting that you're free to
choose
whichever one so if there's enough
tension as opposed to
everybody align like a flock of birds
yeah you i mean you definitely want
that all of the dialectics would be
balanced
um so if you have
someone who is extremely oriented to
self-empowerment and someone who is
extremely oriented to kind of empathy
and compassion
both the dialectic of those is better
than either of them on their own
um if you have both of them inhabiting
being inhabited better than you by the
same person spending time around that
person will probably do
well for you i think the thing you just
mentioned is super important when it
comes to cognitive
schools which is
i think one of the fastest things people
can do to improve their learning
and they're not just cognitive learning
but their
meaningful problem-solving communication
and civic capacity
capacity to participate as a citizen
with other people and making the world
better
is to be seeking dialectical synthesis
all the time
and so in the hegelian sense if you have
a thesis
you have an antithesis so maybe we have
libertarianism on one side and marxist
kind of communism on the other side and
one is arguing that
the individual is the unit of choice
and so we want to uh increase the
freedom and support of individual choice
because as they make more agentic
choices it'll produce a better hole for
everybody
the other side saying well the
individuals are conditioned by their
environment who would choose to be born
into darfur rather than finland
um so we actually need to collectively
make environments
that are good because that the
environment conditions individuals
so you have a thesis and an antithesis
and then hegel's idea is you have a
synthesis which is a kind of higher
order truth that understands
how those relate in a way that neither
of them do
and so it is actually at a higher order
of complexity so the first part would be
can i steal man each of these
can i argue each one well enough that
the proponents of it are like totally
you got that
and not just argue it rhetorically but
can i inhabit it where i can
try to see and feel the world the way
someone seeing and fitting the world
that way would
because once i do then i don't want to
screw those people because there's truth
in it
right and i'm not going to go back to
war with them i'm going to go to finding
solutions it could actually work at a
higher order
if i don't go to a higher order then
there's more
and but then the higher order thing
would be well it seems like the
individual
does affect the commons and the
collective and other people it also
seems like
the collective conditions individuals at
least statistically
and i can cherry pick out the one guy
who got out of the ghetto
um and pulled himself up by his
bootstraps but i can also say
statistically that most people born into
the ghetto show up differently than most
people born into the hamptons
and so unless you want to argue that and
have you take your child from the
hamptons and put them in the ghetto then
like
come on be realistic about this thing so
how do we make
we don't want social systems that make
weak dependent individuals
right so the welfare argument but we
also don't want
no social system that supports
individuals to do better
we want we don't want individuals where
their
self-expression and agency [ __ ] the
environment and everybody else and
employs slave labor and whatever so can
we make it to where
individuals are creating holes that are
better for
conditioning other individuals can we
make it to where we have holes that are
conditioning
increased agency and sovereignty right
that would be the synthesis
so the thing that i'm coming to here is
if people
have that as a frame and sometimes it's
not just thesis and antithesis it's like
eight different views
right can i steal man each view
this is not just can i take the
perspective but am i seeking them am i
actively trying to inhabit other
people's perspective
then can i really try to essentialize it
and argue
the best points of it both the sense
making about reality and the values
why these values actually matter then
just like i want to seek those
perspectives then i want to seek
is there a higher order set of
understandings that could fulfill the
values of
and synthesize the sense making of all
of them simultaneously
maybe i won't get it but i want to be
seeking it and i want to be seeking
progressively better ones
so this is perspective seeking driving
perspective taking
and then seeking synthesis
i think that that one
cognitive disposition might be
the most helpful thing would you put a
title dialectic synthesis
on that process because that seems to be
such a part so like this
rigorous empathy like
like it's not just empathy it's empathy
with rigor like you
really want to understand and embody
different world views and then try to
find a higher order synthesis
okay so i remember last night you told
me when we first met
uh you said that you looked in
somebody's eyes and you felt that you
had
suffered in some ways that they had
suffered and so you could trust them
shared pathos right creates a certain
sense of kind of shared
bonding and shared intimacy so empathy
is actually feeling the suffering of
somebody else and feeling the
the depth of their sentience i don't
want to [ __ ] them anymore
i may not hurt them i don't want to
behave and i don't want my proposition
to go through
when i go and inhabit the perspective of
the other people if they feel that's
really going to mess them up
right and so the rigorous empathy it's
different than just compassion which is
i generally care
like i have a generalized care but i
don't know what it's like to be them
i can never know what it's like to be
them perfectly and that there's a
humility you have to have which is
my most rigorous attempt is still not it
my most rigorous attempt mine to know
what it's like to be a woman is still
not it
i have no question that if i was
actually a woman it would be different
than my best guesses
i have no question if i was actually
black it's be different than my best
guesses
so there's a humility in that which
keeps me listening because i don't think
that i know fully
but i want to and i'm going to keep
trying better too
and then i want to across them and then
i want to say is there a way we can
forward together and not have to be in
war
it has to be something that could meet
the values that everyone holds
it could reconcile the partial
sense-making that everyone holds
and they could offer a way forward that
is more agreeable
than the partial perspectives at war
with each other but the so the more
you succeed at this empathy with
humility
the more you're carrying the burden of
their of
other people's pain essentially this
goes back to the question of do i see us
as one
being or 7.8 billion
i think the
if i'm overwhelmed with my own pain i
can't empathize that much
because i don't have the bandwidth i
don't have the capacity if i don't feel
like i can do something about a
particular problem in the world it's
hard to feel it because it's just too
devastating
and so a lot of people go numb and even
go nihilistic
because they just don't feel the agency
so as i actually become more empowered
as an individual
and have more sense of agency i also
become more empowered to be more
empathetic for others and be more
connected
to that shared burden and want to be
able to make choices
on behalf of and in in benefit of so
this way of living
seems like a way of living that would
solve a lot of problems in society
from a cellular automata perspective so
if you have a bunch of little
like little agents behaving in this way
my intuition there will be interesting
complexities that emerge but my
intuition is
it will create a society that's very
different and recognizably
better than the one we have today
how much like oh wait hold that
question because i want to come back to
it but this brings us back to gerard
which we didn't answer
the conflict theory yes because about
how to get past the conflict theory yes
you know the robert frost poem about the
two paths he never had
time to turn back to the other we're
gonna have to do that quite a lot we're
gonna be
uh living that poem over and over again
but yes
how how to uh let's return back
okay so the rest of the argument goes
you learn to want what other people
want therefore fundamental conflict
based in our desire because we want the
thing that somebody else has
and then people are conf they're in
conflict over trying to get the same
stuff
power status attention physical stuff a
mate whatever it is
and then the we learn the conflict by
watching and so then the conflict
becomes medic so the
and you know we become on the
palestinian side of the israeli side or
the communist capitalist side or the
left or right
politically or whatever it is and until
eventually the conflict energy in the
system builds up so much
that some type of violence is needed to
get the bad guy whoever it is that we're
going to blame
and you know george talks about why
scapegoating was kind of a mechanism to
minimize the amount of violence let's
blame
let's blame it a sec a scapegoat as
being more relevant than they really
were but if we all believe it then we
can all kind of calm down with the
conflict energy
it's a really interesting concept by the
way i mean you went you
beautifully summarized it but the idea
that there's a scapegoat that there's a
this kind of thing naturally leads to a
conflict
and then they find the other some group
that's the other
that's either real artificial as the
cause of the conflict
well it's always artificial because the
cause of the conflict in
gerard is the mimesis of desire itself
and how do we attack that
how do we attack that it's our own
desire so this now gets to something
more like buddha said
right which was desire as the cause of
suffering um
gerard and buddha would kind of agree in
this way
so and so but that's that explains i
mean again it's a compelling
description of human history that we do
tend to
come up with the other and uh okay kind
of i just
i just had such a funny experience with
someone critiquing gerard the other day
in such a
um elegant and beautiful and simple way
it's a
a friend who's uh
grew up aboriginal australian uh is a
scholar of
aboriginal social technologies
and he's like nah man gerard just made
[ __ ] up about how tribes work like we
come from a tribe we've got tens of
thousands of years and we didn't have
increasing conflict and then scapegoat
and kill someone we'd have a little bit
of conflict and then we would dance
and then everybody'd be fine like we'd
dance around the campfire everyone would
like kind of physically get the energy
out we'd look in each other's eyes we'd
have positive bonding
and then we're fine and nobody no
scapegoats and
i think that's called the joe rogan
theory of desire which is
uh he's like all all of human problems
have to do with the fact that you don't
do enough hard [ __ ] in your day
uh so maybe maybe you could just dance
it because he says like
doing exercise and running on the
treadmill gets gets all the demons out
maybe just dance and gets all the demons
out
so this is why i say we have to be
careful with taking an idea
that seems too explanatory and then
taking it as a given and then saying
well now that we're stuck with the fact
that
conflict is inexorable because human
because memetic desire and therefore how
do we deal with the inexorability of the
conflict and how to sublimate violence
well
no the whole thing might be actually
gibberish meaning it's only true in
certain
conditions and other conditions it's not
true so the deeper question is under
which conditions
is that true under which conditions is
it not true what do those other
conditions make possible and look like
and in general we should stay with
really compelling models
of reality because there's something
about about our brains that these models
become sticky
and we can't even think outside of them
so it's not that we stay away from them
it's that we know that the model
of reality is never reality that's the
key thing
humility again it goes back to just
having the humility that you don't have
a perfect model of reality there's an
ep the model of reality could never be
reality the process of modeling is
inherently
information reduction and
i can never show that the unknown
unknown set has been factored
um it's back to the cellular automata
you can't
you can't uh put the uh the genie back
in the bottle
like when you realize it's unfortunately
sadly impossible to um
to create a model of cellular automata
even if you know the basic rules
that predict to even any degree of
accuracy
what uh um how that
system will evolve which is fascinating
mathematically sorry i i think about it
quite a lot
it's very annoying wolfram has this rule
like you should be able to predict it
it's so simple
but you can't predict what's going to be
like there's a there's a
problem he defines they try to predict
some aspect of the middle
middle column of the system just
anything about it
what's gonna happen in the future and
you can't you can't
it sucks because then we can't make
sense of this world
you know really in a reality in a
definitive way
it's always like in the striving like it
we're always striving yeah i don't think
this sucks
that so that's a feature not a bug well
that's assuming a designer um i would
say i don't think it sucks
i think it's not only beautiful but
maybe necessary for beauty
you